the Joe Rogan experience times there's
people that I'm like yeah but you're
[ __ ] up all day every day yeah if you
have an addictive personality and you
have a problem with anything there's a
lot of people that get into that kratom
stuff do you know what that stuff is
mm-hmm
kratom is it's like a plant-based I
think people are trying to call it an
opiate I don't know if it's technically
an opiate but it's legal you can buy it
and helps people it actually alleviates
a lot of the symptoms of opiates and it
acts as a mild stimulant when you take a
little bit of it like if you take two
pills it's like a cup of coffee it's
like oh I like this is nice but then I
said I wonder what it's like like and I
was asking a friend of mine who takes a
long time ago how much do you take and
he's like I take 10 pills
I know 10 you take 10 like what the [ __ ]
is that like so I did it I tried it I
think I took eight I don't think I took
ten and I was [ __ ] up I was like oh
you guys are getting high yeah like this
is your hi I'm Rui right now like this
is not like you're not sober don't tell
me you're sober and you taking eight
pills of crazy like that stuff gets you
high right you can buy it legally but
it's weird high it's like everything
functions like your muscles and your
arms and everything moves the way it's
supposed to it doesn't feel like you're
uncoordinated or you're tripping and
stumbling or anything like that but your
brain is like this is not sober it's
just like screaming this is not sober
but it's a different kind of this is not
sober interesting yeah you're not you
like I could have a conversation with
you and you might not even know that it
was [ __ ] up on this stuff right and I
could go lift weights I gonna go do
something you wouldn't it wouldn't
impair like you go running on that stuff
so is it like a heady buzz or like a
body to anything right yeah it's a head
it's a weird one like I was really
shocked at how high I got hmm because
that felt like because that's what
someone said they said if you take two
pills it has a mild stimulant effect
somewhere in a cup of coffee but if you
take multiple pills then it becomes more
of like a like a downer or not another
downer more relaxing more looking at
opiate right but I didn't realize how
[ __ ] up you actually get like you get
pretty [ __ ] up and then you get a
tolerance for it so that a lot of these
guys are taking like ten pills then
going to the gym no I need it for my
back I'm like
blast it yeah that's like that was booze
and all drugs it feels like you kind of
chase that yeah thing I mean that's yeah
yeah well that's the thing right it's
like we were talking about with
smartphones or like we were talking
about video games like things get a get
away from you yeah that's part of the
problem being a comic right like all of
us there's something wrong with your
brain to want to do this right yeah I
think there's definitely some sort of
desire there's some attention you didn't
get somewhere something wrong you're
upset about it and so when you're not on
stage or when you are is you're trying
to do something else to make you forget
about that yeah attention or affection
you didn't get somewhere along the line
yeah it's so [ __ ] if you can harness
it though
like that I didn't get enough attention
you can be super beneficial it gives you
insight yeah it'll give you motivation
if you can harness it yeah it's
interesting to go that sort of self
reflecting and therapy or whatever that
whatever your method is or people do it
with mushrooms or whatever but then
introspective of like oh those moments
where you're like I'm doing that because
of that that's neat
yeah then there's the next step of not
no longer doing the things you don't
want to do because of that or the habits
that you have and the next step you go
to the rhabdo center and malibu start
doing acid Oh where's Maui Duncan Duncan
goes to Maui every year hangs Owen ROM
Dawson Wow
they meditate
[Applause]